not every Hollywood release could be a
home run but you should at least be able
to expect some decent entertainment when
you go to the theater every so often
however even great filmmakers will turn
out a pretty terrible movie in 2018
these are the films that perked up our
ears and then sent us home with our
hearts unfulfilled our wallets empty and
her forehead sore from all the
face-palming these are the worst movies
of the year so far and they sure aren't
pretty insidious the last key fans of
the insidious series started getting
goosebumps of anticipation when the
fourth installment was announced in 2016
but it wasn't long before we saw signs
of trouble insidious the last keys
release date was pushed back from
October 2017 to January of 2018 and as
you probably know January is an exactly
prime territory for horror releases so
when the film finally hit theaters the
reason for the shuffle became extremely
apparent it isn't very good critics
hammered insidious the last key for it's
confused tone and for playing like a
mishmash of well-worn horror tropes but
diminishing creative returns don't
always translate to diminishing box
office returns the film's worldwide
gross is actually the best of the entire
series meaning that insidious 5 has all
been inevitable here's hoping the next
installment finds a way to deliver some
bonafide scares while moving all those
tickets proud Mary on the surface proud
Mary seemed like a sure thing it's the
story of a contract killer played by the
immensely talented
taraji fee Henson who finds herself
responsible for the welfare of a young
boy after a job goes sideways the
exciting trailers promised a great
performance from Henson and she
delivered but unfortunately she did so
in a film that felt like it was slapped
together out of spare parts the 14
million dollar flick did dismal business
worldwide making it a certified flop the
1517 to Paris Clint Eastwood has a
pretty good track record as a director
and an even better one as a director
have historical dramas so expectations
were high for the
1517 to Paris the true story of a trio
of American soldiers who found
themselves in the middle of an attempted
terrorist attack on a train while
travelling in Europe the actual story is
a harrowing account and Eastwood even
recruited the soldiers to play
themselves in the movie unfortunately it
turns out that one spectacular act of
heroism doesn't necessarily make for an
entertaining film and real-life heroes
don't always make great actors even the
stars themselves had different ideas on
who should have been in the film you
must have had ideas in your head of who
was gonna who did you want to play you
is that guy from one of the other
problems the critics had was that the
portrayal of the actual incident was
fairly short with nearly 2/3 of the
film's run time devoted to exposition
while the main action sequence was
praised everything surrounding it was a
disappointment and the 1517 to Paris
arrives at the station to be greeted by
generally indifferent audiences midnight
sun music video director turned
filmmaker scott sphere scored a minor
hit with his first big-screen
directorial effort step up revolution a
solid if an essential addition to be
step-up series for his next trick spear
mounted an adaptation of the 2006
japanese feature midnight sun starring
former Disney star bella thorne
alongside none other than patrick
Schwarzenegger it's the story of a
teenage girl with a rare and
life-threatening genetic sensitivity to
sunlight who is finally asked out by her
secret crush but instead of tugging at
the audience's heartstrings the film
left critics and audiences alike feeling
cold with its gimmicky portrayal of an
actual terminal condition the film
opened to a dismal four million dollar
opening weekend while critics far and
wide advised film goers to save their
money forever my girl writer director
Bethany Ashton wolf helmed her second
big-screen effort with forever my girl
the story of the country music star who
returns home for the funeral of a friend
only to face the lost love he left
behind if that description strikes you
is the type of thing Nicholas Sparks
might have come up with you're certainly
not alone and that's part of the problem
critics couldn't help but note that
forever failed even to clear the bar
typically set by sparks formulaic film
stories
the film seemed to bring out the worst
and practically every critic who viewed
it with most reviewers feeling that it
barely lived up to the standards of a
Lifetime movie I don't know that I was
pregnant until a couple weeks after I
was supposed to be our wedding day the
picture only managed a 16 million dollar
haul during its theatrical run further
indication that 2018 is decidedly not
shaping up to be a great year for
romantic dramas Sherlock gnomes the 2011
animated romp
Gnomeo and Juliet was a surprise hit
raking in nearly 200 million dollars at
the worldwide box office the story is
basically a retelling of Shakespeare's
famous star-crossed tragedy but with
well garden gnomes and also slightly
less suicide to bury you under the patio
the film earned mixed reviews but its
box office returns were more than enough
to guarantee a sequel Sherlock gnomes
spent six years in development but was
finally released to audiences in 2018
unfortunately all of those years weren't
spent crafting a you know watchable
movie despite the presence of Johnny
Depp in the title role and Chua tell
Ejiofor as Watson critics and audiences
were bored to tears by this outing who
needs a ship nor ship xolali many noted
that like the original the film seems to
exist as a delivery service for the
music of executive producer Elton John
the film's box office struggles may mean
that we'll be spared another trip to
Nome world in the future however so at
least there's that
death wish there may not be a major
Hollywood film that has ever arrived
with worse timing than death wish the
2018 remake features Bruce Willis as
Paul Kersey and everyday Joe whose
daughter and wife are assaulted by thugs
when the police don't do anything he
takes matters into his own hands so
there's nothing that I can do is that
what your son can have faith critics
certainly took note of the film's
incredibly poor timing given that the
Stoneman Douglas high school shooting
had occurred just a few weeks earlier
but aside from that death wish just
doesn't really work as a movie anyway
viewed as a pure action film it's
surprisingly sluggish the Charles
Bronson original famously spawned four
sequels of diminishing returns and
escalating insanity
what are those teeth with this version
failing to strike box-office gold
history probably won't repeat itself
the Cloverfield paradox during the Super
Bowl in February 2018 a surprise trailer
dropped for the Cloverfield paradox the
third installment in JJ Abrams loosely
connected sci-fi horror series the flick
was released to Netflix directly after
the game and millions of eager fans
tuned in to be supremely disappointed
despite the presence of an impressive
cast paradox was a disappointing dud
with much of the criticism heaped on its
undercooked characters and exposition
heavy script the film was originally
intended for a theatrical release and
Paramount CEO Andrew Gumpert explained
why the decision was made to distribute
it on Netflix saying we all decided that
there were things about it that made us
have a pause about its commercial
playability in the traditional manner if
you think that seems like a delicately
worded way of saying the film was the
opposite of good well you may be onto
something
that's my arm Winchester on paper
Winchester sounded like the kind of
horror slam-dunk that comes along once
every decade or so a supernatural Fright
Fest based on the spooky true story of
Sarah Winchester who spent years
building the mother of all haunted
houses while the noise as well as
destruction they want me to build a
doctor
the spirits writing / directing duo the
spirit brothers had recently scored a
nifty sci-fi hit with 2015's
predestination and with Helen Mirren in
the lead role of Winchester the stars
were all aligned so how did it go so
terribly wrong critics agreed that it
represented a hugely missed opportunity
that led to an utterly forgettable film
the spirits were taken to task for
choosing jump-scares / atmosphere in the
end Winchester became perhaps the most
disappointing film of the year so far
Fifty Shades breathe nobody thought the
third installment of the Fifty Shades
series would become a critical hit and
well nobody was disappointed
despite raking in almost 370 million
dollars worldwide Fifty Shades freed was
torn apart by critics the few positive
reviews tended to highlight its merits
as unintentional satire rather than any
redeeming qualities it might have but
there is one cinematic achievement that
Fifty Shades freed deserves credit for
putting an end to the Fifty Shades
series A Wrinkle and time
expectations were sky-high for director
Ava Duvernay 's adaptation of the
classic young adult novel a wrinkle in
time with an amazing cast that included
storm read
Reese Witherspoon and Oprah Winfrey the
film looked like it'd be another winner
for Disney but unfortunately it fell
surprisingly flat with critics and
posted flat box-office receipts to match
not surprisingly the negative reviews
mostly focused on the disappointment
fans of the novel felt as the adaptation
ultimately failed to match the source
materials tone a wrinkle in time is a
novel that most fans have always
considered unadaptable and it looks like
they were right one review described it
as a film that does
not stop feeling generic another hinted
that the film might have been improved
with better editing apparently it wasn't
just one thing that went wrong
but if you put them all together a
wrinkle in time is nothing more than a
bright colorful dud the outsider the
last five years or so have been full of
ups and downs for Jared Leto the actor
went from an Oscar win for his role in
Dallas buyers club to a target for
critical disdain after his portrayal of
the Joker in Suicide Squad and letõs
career roller-coaster continues with the
Netflix original film the outsider in
this movie Leto stars as a former
American soldier who joins the Yakuza in
post-world War 2 Japan a character that
has been called among the least engaging
cinematic protagonists in recent memory
the film itself was mercilessly bashed
as a clueless misfire and another big
swing and a Miss for Leto ouch acrimony
it's safe to say that taraji P Henson is
having a rough year in addition to the
colossal disappointment that was proud
marry she takes the lead role in
acrimony the latest film from Tyler
Perry Henson plays a wife who's cheating
husband pushes her to the brink of
insanity but her presence simply wasn't
enough to save this limp derivative
thriller reviews compared the movie to a
slower less interesting version of fatal
attraction despite Perry's name
virtually guaranteeing a profit acrimony
failed to even match the box-office
performance of his latest Madea movie
which is saying a lot
hush I'm trying to be in Kakariko thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]